so him following me every step I'm
taking and trying to get my number is
what happened so we're not saying that
it doesn't happen we're just saying it's
not the majority of me and like I said
maybe again my figure my figure might
attract a lot more men than someone or
someone else might be size six and not
attracted right men might not be
attracted to that my figure might be
what attracts them and when I go on the
streets of Marrakesh they might feel
like oh this is a nice one I don't know
I can't say my experience with someone
else is going to be exactly the same but
what I have experienced when I have gone
to certain countries I have been
physically touched and again maybe it's
because I'm too smiley sometimes when
I'm too smiley guys think they can
physically just come and get a bit more
comfortable so I had to be a bit more
standoffish okay I'm going to read Super
Chat
um guys make sure you like the video
that is the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these live
streams so if you think this is
entertaining you like the topics that we
cover and you think it's important that
people watch make sure you like the
video
um we are using all super chats to get
blessing an 8K camera we're going to be
filming some reaction videos and we I
want you guys to see the freckles on my
face that is what I want I want to be so
clear you can literally see the freckles
on my face
um so make sure you send donations to
help us raise that we're about I don't
know 2 000 short from that so make sure
you send donations for that so zero
Fallout one the men that approached her
were from from Greenpeace making sure
she wasn't
accidentally harpooned 90 free Tope
women act like celebrities they treat
men like Paparazzi the men in your life
are sad you view men as bad we love you
Auntie Christopher cerdak approach her
for her figure only to offer some celery
in a diet book
um zero Fallout she's a Madison
um tracks advances from attractive guys
are accepted differently from less
desirable guys doing the same approach
it's Russian Roulette for a guy to
approach women they don't know whether
or she'll accept you Bill Bill Chris why
are we complaining Western men Western
men with men from third world countries
and acting like they're the same public
sculpture sadly the truth is that it's
more beneficial to be a toxic man than a
nice guy because women will choose the
toxic guy over the nice guy I'm
Christopher surdak pillow girl just
accept that you're a misandrous and call
it a day you will never be married 90
free Tope there's a study of men of a
man on dating sites telling women he's a
pedo but still got dates because he was
hot based on their messages to him Jesus
Christ
Peter Mitchell um for the girl in the
black I would treat you right and I have
my own goals like Andy said the sex
though but I wouldn't cheat or do you
wrong
um dub Man Pearl explained to women that
we don't care about their money because
we are not going to we're not going to
be able to spend your money Christopher
surdack using words without knowing what
they actually mean or making up
definitions based on your feelings this
is the definition of modern women men
use words to describe reality women use
it to try to change it came all you
girls don't know how a hard a hard on
works we wake up it's there it's we are
thinking be or be thinking it's there we
go to bed it's there been fact it
doesn't show up when we worry it's our
Terry Crews 90 Frito pie pie not pay
please please the super chats a little
bit slower
um 90 Frito pie sex isn't the main thing
but I don't buy a house just for the
bathroom don't let me use it once a
month don't respect don't restrict me
cheating for man is providing and
resources for another woman not sex we
don't care about the nuts women thinking
cheating is sex but also say that sex is
just physical the UK Economist is it
true that women enjoy sleeping with a
non-committed man but not with a
provider husband 93 Tope who let garbage
batch doll speak passive aggressive girl
beside and he keep up the good work of
splitting up the family Almighty Tian
Auntie is spitting now these
um
oh these modern women are lazy um Fox
that man doesn't want you he will either
seize you as just sex or he knows
something about your past that he
doesn't forgive you for but won't tell
you broke homes need to go to jail she's
got a big reason the money thing is
capped Tim nurath all excuses I'm
married we both work together and know
that we are both not perfect I
acknowledge I'm wrong she acknowledges
she's wrong but I can't I can see here
you haven't said anything about your
critiques always someone else's fault
Sadie daughter six years old traumatized
at Uni by a guy she keeps bringing up
could it be
daughter is six years old traumatized at
Uni by guy she keeps bringing up could
it be the kid is his and not her
husbands could explain the separation
Alice a call him Russell Warren love it
um Ruma God bless you Pearl you look as
tired you look as tired as most men feel
and we do this every day these young
women better believe that altruistic
ideals as much as they can and not see
the correct path isn't white or black
but gray
um Almighty tan she's capping she was
the problem LSA shorty with the tired
pig or tiger pillow is all caps Doom
tracks if he's not where he wants to be
if he's not where it wants to be
wouldn't it be a great idea to be that
woman who would help him get there
wouldn't that make your bond with him
stronger knowing you were with him at
the start
um boss Auntie told us how to keep a man
a few shows back a few shows back Full
Belly empty sack and peace
um zero Fallout she is a former 304
disguised as a tradcon traditional con
artist no wonder her husband doesn't
want to get back with her she's full of
cap tracks um she's a walking
contradiction says one thing um but does
another tries to get herself out of a
contradiction Loop but buries herself
deeper and goes to add gas to the fire
when some of the girls agree with her um
how Cheryl Chad here first time caller
the separated wife is genuine she's
looking to figure out the female proverb
of Jane Austen in this in the streets
and 50 Shades in the sheets ask cool
Auntie how to regain proper femininity
she brings to the bedroom spice the
couples are looking for um Russell
Warren interesting um Doug MPA the girl
on the couch is a typical Western woman
encouraging bro broken homes and single
Parenthood black cultures lost what a
shame Goku with Hellcat wow that woman
is dishonest as hell Russell Warren lead
by example don't worry about teaching
lessons it usually comes off sideways
Paula what she is saying is if a better
option
if a better option than my husband will
appear I'm gone life is not a fairy pale
fairy tale go back to your husband and
work out with your family
um Karen Hunter ma'am in the back it
doesn't matter they're already together
so they should get it together they the
the through the obstacle the strength is
gained Tim Jennings hot take both
parties are responsible for sex men have
a duty to protect women's Purity and
women have a duty to Value their only
Purity dubman Pearl asked the panel if a
guy told you I want to be with you and
still have other women would you say
sounds great thanks for being honest
Alistair Horton Psy more evidence in
motion is a weakness it's consistent and
endless um Ona hi I live in Nigeria we
don't like baby mamas oh that's from the
last show oh shoot
damn all right
um oh wait no no I lied that was from
the show okay sorry they keep going
um Omi Roma a man will not cheat if his
woman drains him every day he will not
have the energy to do so um rashu
bezos's ex-wife is already getting a
divorce um Tim Jennings after watching
the past eight episodes it seems like
abstinence is the way to go solves all
the problems no comparisons no messy
relationships making dating choices
based on all the other stuff besides sex
Grindr women will mess up your car if
you tell them the truth okay I actually
it's funny they brought up Jeff oh does
anyone have anything to say to the super
chats I'm sorry I didn't say them they
did
that one that was super fast yeah
um there's always a lot um okay so today
we're going to talk about
Jeff bezos's ex-wife
so do everyone know who Jeff Bezos is
Auntie you don't
Amazon guy Amazon I don't know if Amazon
it's like one of the so he's one of the
richest
he's one of the richest men on the
planet
um and so about a couple years ago it
came out that he was cheating on his
wife at the time and his wife was there
from the beginning so she was like
they've been together I don't know like
20 years something like that and she
divorced him took half the money and got
remarried
and at the time everyone was saying I
was so sweet she married a teacher
and it all seemed like you know she got
the fairy tale ending however
she is now divorcing her second husband
so knowing that women typically don't do
well
um
when they date someone that's like less
than their their EX in their head should
she have stayed with Jeff
knowing that she can't do better
what
I think Bill Gates didn't he get
divorced yeah yeah yeah I guess you
wouldn't have known she can't do better
until she
we know people think you know the grass
is greener and if you're in that Circle
like you're I guess you're what you're
that like the people you're you've got
accessible to you know are different
you're in a different war game like is
that you know when you feed a celebrity
I am now in this world I've got access
to of our villainous I guess so she
wouldn't have known she couldn't do
better when she's already in that world
that's a teacher like what's it I mean
what she knows that now but she probably
falls on her so she probably thought
it's better to date why did they why did
they split up because he cheated is
she became the richest woman in the
world
one at a time Auntie will go ahead he
cheated did they say that he was G10
he stepped out how do you know maybe she
weren't giving him no six
but she could have forgiven him talk
about it look how long they've been
together
but you were saying that if a woman
stays she's stupid then so if she stayed
with him after he cheated would she not
be stupid and look what she done and
look what she done made more of a fool
of herself she might as well stay down
Auntie didn't Auntie didn't say you're
stupid she says the girls are stupid
when they get back with the guy and then
complain about him cheating so like you
you make his life a living hell you
chose to get back with him and maybe
yeah maybe she could have given them
yeah maybe she couldn't
maybe she's just thinking about the
money she will get if she divorce him
that she can start again I think that
but she should have gonna find another
billionaire to match her money then I I
do think he was wrong though because I
do I do believe that if a woman was
there from the start then you owe her
that level of loyalty for helping you
get to the position you got to I only
believe that if he remarries or finds a
new woman then he'd just do the [ __ ] you
like because she's bite into a lifestyle
that she can never I want to know if she
gets divorced or she got get the teacher
half oh no of course not she'll be smart
to do prenup just checking yeah I hope
she did a printout oh [ __ ] smart enough
why do you hope she do the prenup so
it's nice for her to take that but it's
not nice to someone to do to her yeah
because he was there in the beginning
did he exactly
she didn't get that money from the
beginning yeah she helped her husband
but she didn't like yeah yeah she didn't
make the money she took care of the
family she did her yeah but is that come
on half his fortune you're telling me if
it was her first you could have built
Amazon by herself no he she didn't do
that but you know the thing is that was
their partnership right that was what
they worked together it's like it's like
men when they used to pay off the
mortgage when women then divorced they
were entitled to laugh only because they
couldn't earn and they were exactly
to build that fortune you know the thing
is right it's entitled to his money like
that's so much like I'm just thinking
from the man's point of view like if I'm
building this business right and I and I
have a like I have a boyfriend or a
husband right why why would he leave and
get half if I built it so why do women
feel entitled because with them yet say
say they've got children he obviously
had to work like tirelessly to build
Amazon right she was probably I don't
know I don't know the situation I know
the story but let's just say she was at
home she held down the home for him to
be able to to build that I definitely
it's not it's not worth half of Amazon
you know billions of dollars you wanted
to raise two kids oh come on I know
something I grew up I grew up with
nannies I grew up with nannies that
shit's like twelve dollars an hour
I don't know if they had nannies or
whatever but I mean a woman staying at
home to take care of kids is hard work
no that's why you had nannies Billy
otherwise
billions of dollars you know the thing
is right is that she got half his money
But the teacher I would like to see what
he does with his half because Amazon's
still going to stay there I bet he still
makes more money than she does with hers
a bit sooner or later she's got no money
and he's still building on his she wants
to give her money away that'd be cool
then she shouldn't have taken it in the
first place
in the first place if you're not gonna
want it no that's different I can take
money from you and then give it to
whoever I want to give and spend however
I want to spend it but I'm not going to
decline the money because I'm going to
give it away I'd like to see it I don't
think she should give it away can I say
I think just Jeff Bezos doesn't give a
[ __ ] how about that because simply
because that's his ex-wife and she got
half the money but he's got his money
and you know this is going to make more
that's the right to see he don't give a
[ __ ] because it's Jeff Bezos the average
man has to give a [ __ ] because that's
his livelihood done I get you but this
is in context of the situation I don't
think Jeff Bezos
he doesn't care because at the end of
the day maybe she said okay what all
about this what about this would you
rather
you lose your money yeah but and you
don't have to deal with that woman
that's weighing you down for the rest of
your life and you can make some more
money and be happy and content I I agree
with you he's so rich he probably I
doubt he cares yeah he's so rich but but
the point is like why do as women we
feel entitled to a man's money because
you helped raise the kid no but that's a
lot in the states right this doesn't
apply like in most other okay but we're
not we're in the UK even in the UK women
don't naturally that's not good
that's not true um even I don't
necessarily know what it is for divorce
but from I've heard a lot of like I get
DMS from people constantly and I've
gotten horror stories from Men in the UK
and I I do Street interviews horror
stories of Child Support so it's it's no
different you're in the west we're not
talking about global